and uh i think that's how to choose
openings he does open with the king's
pawn so we are likely to see the
sicilian defense
french defense
magnus did use this yesterday to beat
anish giri
yeah well
i don't think we could expect either of
those moves really i mean e4
from hands is a bit of a surprise and e6
even though magnus did play is it
surprising what variation will hans now
play a number of moves to play here
david from that white could play right i
suspect he's gonna pick up his knight
and uh defend the pawn in the center i
mean the trendy line is the advance now
there's been some sort of new ideas in
the advanced variation where uh white
often gives up a pawn and he has though
played played your move you've anchored
a tarash variation
so yeah maybe white's safest kind of
most secure
choice in that position just
even if black plays very accurately here
it tends to lead to equal-ish positions
so hands not going for the advanced
variation pushing white's central pawns
forward gaining space which
uh kind of would lead to more
double-edged scenarios okay magnus
challenging the center
still well-known stuff
white's night come out comes out i had
this position myself in the olympiad uh
from the white side but okay my opponent
didn't choose this move
trading off a set of pawns in the center
aneesh giri in his chestable course does
recommend bringing black's queenside
knight out now to challenge white's
knight in the center of the board
and
will
either of these two players have studied
anishigiri's french course on chesapeal
there are some other moves here black
can bring either night out
i think those are the two most trendy
moves in this position
what is magnus gonna do he needs to
surprise hands right normally when you
have the black pieces it's hard to win
against any kind of grandmaster opponent
but you need some
some kind of surprise just to throw them
off balance to kind of
nullify the opening
advantage that white traditionally has
yeah it's all very well known stuff this
i mean it's been played thousands of
times before and
i guess you might have some games there
you've got yeah i have i have lots of
games in the database i even have games
where magnus has been playing this
opening with the white pieces against
fabiano carolina and winning i mean i
have to say
i mean up until yesterday's game against
anish giri you know magnus really
doesn't tend to play this opening with
the black pieces but he is following
anish's recommendation
and uh there's going to be some trades
still
within uh very well known territory here
black's dart squared bishop coming out i
think that's what uh anish giri
recommends in his course
um the older move here is black's queen
um
just developing maybe magnus and anish
have been working together you know some
of those two great friends magnus and
anish preparing hard there were two very
theoretically important games in the
olympiad just a couple of weeks ago in
this position where black pushed his
king's pawn forward
one square uh just to block the center
occupy as many central squares as
possible so is magnus go going to go for
the most critical move which has
featured recently in some high level
games or is he going to just try
and uh confuse hans with maybe a less
well-known move
still it feels like a psychological
battle at this early stage hans playing
almost instantly every move magnus is
the one taking uh pause here and there
magnus clearly knows what's going on or
what he wants to play but uh he's trying
to guess what will make hans the most
uncomfortable maybe he's trying to just
slow the pace down and get it into
because in the last last game he was
matching hands right by like tempo so
maybe he's trying to sort of just get it
into his you know control get control on
the game by slowing houses pace down uh
a little bit and
you know because it didn't work well the
last game that's for sure yeah that's my
excuse for getting in time travel just
slowing things down you know
controlling the pace of the game at
least in the initial phase david
whatever you do keep doing it
can we see the level again
comes with a warning because uh most
people actually
cannot handle time pressure very well i
mean
you make mistakes but
david
different level and magnus developing
his night and i have to say this has
been such a thrilling start
to day two of the ftx crypto cup and of
course we love it when you're at home
also join in all that fun action and
excitement
and show us your selfies where are you
watching the tour from how are you
watching it who you're watching with we
love to see your pictures and we will
feature them on the show and as always
you can send us your thoughts and uh we
will again if you tweet us using the
hashtag chestchat we will show them on
the screen yes
we do love your selfies and uh remember
actually so uh we know you're watching
from all around the world and we're so
excited to have viewers from all around
the world but for the two final days of
the fdx crypto cup in miami it is
possible to go to the venue as a
spectator
which i think will be a lot of fun you
can read all about this on
chess24.com tour how you can get your
tickets and go to miami to watch these
top chess players in action
that's so cool that you can actually go
in person and get a feel of the whole
vibe there because i can tell you it's
really special it is so intense playing
here on the oslo esports arena i mean it
was just incredible yeah you know just
to see the emotion you get up close and
personal and uh meanwhile okay the
action is still continuing because the
players are simply developing their
pieces but at the same time the skeleton
has been built you know white has
definitely
marked out their intentions it's going
to be happening on the right side of the
board and magnus is going to be relying
on his supremacy there in the center
yeah i can i think we can definitely
state that magnus wants to strike back
immediately with black he's not gone for
anything solid he's playing very
provocative chess allowing white to
establish this uh kind of central pawn
on e5 and okay he's trying to gain a bit
more space here this is still relatively
uh kind of well known at least the ideas
i'm not sure about the exact move order
which i think is a bit rare but uh yeah
there's a big threat on the board at
least for magnus he wants to trap
white's bishop in the center of the
board
if he can continue pushing that pawn
forward so
the key factor is right now white's pawn
here is as long as he can maintain it it
kind of cuts the board in half if
black's king for example if white just
pushes the pawn out if black's king ever
castles it's going to be in big danger
on this side white's queen can come
forward to start attacking white's
knight can leap forward and there might
be some ideas of sacrifices breaking
open the black king something we call a
greek gift
and i think this would be very dangerous
for black so that's why magnus right now
he's not committing his king to where he
knows hans wants to attack
instead pushing this pawn as we
mentioned the threat is to push it
further forward for example if white
makes a nothing move and this bishop now
are trapped so hans needs to stop it and
two ways to stop it
stop this pawn pushing forward either as
i mentioned earlier you can push this
pawn just to control this square but
maybe you loosen some dark squares on
this side of the board these dart
squares now are under black's control um
the other option but you have to time it
correctly is to push this pawn forward
and
this does allow black at some point
later for example if he moves his bishop
to open up the center either gaining
space or by trading a set of pawns and
he will have a good bishop on this
diagonal so
still very well known plans is just
putting them together in the right order
whose position would you prefer here
guys white or black from the opening
i mean i've played sort of the french
defense most of my life and uh i'm the
one thing i is always very scary is why
it's pawn in the center of the board
gives white so many good attacking
chances
as you pointed out dave with black ever
castles king side white has this
ready-made attack and in the french
defense
white's light squad squared bishop in
the middle of the board is just such a
fantastic piece and that piece is always
dangerous to black so even though i play
the french defense a lot i i prefer
white's position generally because i
like attacking and as you said this is a
very provocative choice from magnus
because hands is getting a position he
likes he's getting a position where he
can attack at some point he's playing
one of your moves there and he's got a
position where magnus's king is always
going to be a little bit fragile so uh
still obviously early days but
personally i think i think i'd go for
white in this position at the moment
so how about you ivanka yeah i mean my
first instinct is to go with the white
pieces as well you know just because
white house got this beautiful light
square bishop it's on the dream diagonal
um but then again
i you know i kind of feel like i'm
morally obliged to kind of say black
because i kind of play this pawn
structure myself and uh you know black
does have really good long-term
prospects if he withstands white's
initiative and i love long-term
prospects so i'm gonna go
black
yeah
you mentioned the long-term prospects uh
i guess it all lies on this pawn short
term it's a great attacking weapon it
controls so many squares but magnus if
he can somehow
trade off these bishops if you can
somehow trade off these queens then long
term this pawn is actually a target it's
born as a weakness white has
overstretched
so it looks slightly counter-intuitive
magnus has now castled it looks like the
encounter intuitive to kind of be left
with these weak isolated pawns on the
queen side but magnus does have these
great two bishops and these bishops do
control quite a lot of important squares
and also an outpost for the black knight
if it needs
in the center of the board so still a
lot to play for
all three results definitely possible in
this one you know quite funnily when you
were um you know talking about the
opening um i was just wondering is hands
named after han solo
you know one of the most famous like
characters in films because you know
they kind of seem to have that
rebellious streak and then i started
looking up the best quotes that han solo
has actually said and the most popular
quote apparently is uh he's
he says in one of the films he said you
like me because i'm a scoundrel there
aren't enough scoundrels in life
and i thought yeah
that's that's like you know i can see
some similarities there so i was
thinking like there's maybe maybe a bit
of hand solo going on right
with hands maybe his big idol
possibly possibly yes yes
so i've just been looking at han solo
quotes
part of the work of course you know so
and his second most popular quote last
one i mentioned is you know sometimes i
amaze myself
that sounds like anthony
that could be after that first game
something you would say so yeah it was
quite maybe in the next star wars movie
they'll have han solo say something like
uh you know let the
fight speak for itself right yeah
something inspired by hans niemann
i might have just jinxed him simon
because i think hans is just i'm not
sure what he's blunded or sacrificed to
porn uh in the current position and
we've just seen magnus eliminate the
white knight
i have oh i'm slightly afraid for hans
now because uh the position is
simplifying which doesn't favor him we
mentioned hans wants complex positions
but uh let's just rest uh kind of
retrace our steps here just two moves
ago he played his bishop to this square
blocking the queen's defense of this
pawn and after the queen's defense was
taken away the elimination of this
knight does mean that okay we want to
capture with the queen we don't want to
wreck the white pawn structure in front
of our king uh ideally
so if we take with the queen now
suddenly this key pawn that we've
highlighted that we've talked about it
does drop and okay we will see this
happen magnus immediately eliminates
this pawn and not only has black one
upon he does have an attack on this
square i think hans his idea was to take
this black pawn back but now there are a
couple of problems first of all um i
don't really see what the problem is
with just moving the queen to the side
hitting these two bishops kind of
skewering them hitting this pawn as well
also i'm slightly
i'm slightly tempted to grab this pawn
as black or if you want to be super
flashy as magnus you can maybe even grab
this pawn with a check and uh after
white's king take uh kind of takes the
bishop back comes out there is a double
attack a fork hitting the king and
winning the of the white bishop the next
move black will come out pawn up in all
of these variations
wow yeah i just don't see what hans has
in mind and the fact that he's paused to
think okay this is the current position
the fact that han's paws there means
that uh he is unsure as well he's a bit
nervous about what is to come hmm
so magnus he's got a choice of this pawn
this pawn or a safe move just maybe
moving his queen all right my magnus
carlsen is in the move and again we hear
the rain pouring on the roof here in the
studio in oslo so let's get away from
this awful weather in oslo and head to
the beautiful weather in miami i hear
rumors about 36 degrees celsius
yeah that's the time when you want to
bring a jacket and really
feel this weather outside it's so humid
you can't even begin to believe it but i
have something to cool me down because i
have one of the coolest gm's there is
right now alejandra ramirez you are here
in miami what are you doing here now
well i'm here as a spectator uh this is
one of the best events that's happened
in america in a very long time outside
of st louis so i couldn't miss it i'm
happy to be here the fact that it's warm
and beautiful miami well it added to the
equation well you're coming straight
from tonight so you must be pretty
acclimatized to this weather how is it
feeling here compared to there oh
they're both hot but in completely
different ways and i'm happy to be back
in america but i had such a blast in
chennai i was there as the u.s women's
coach and we had an amazing resurgence
basically two different tournaments one
before the bermuda party and one after
and after we kind of crushed it we're
able able to go from all the way from
42nd place which was our low to fourth
place finish so we had a great event and
i'm very happy to have finished with
that but taking a little break here and
we're enjoying chats from the outside
point of view yeah but i mean as an
american i got to ask you about hans
neiman and his game against mungus
carlson today how would you summarize
how they've been playing so far i think
hans is a very hungry player especially
after the olympia he's one of those
players that because of his federation
wasn't able to go there and he sees all
these youngsters at about his age
the uzbeks and they're really coming in
strong they had amazing performances in
the olympia they're headlining
everything and hans is saying look guys
i'm here i'm very good i want to make a
name for myself so he's taking the
chances that he gets here at this cup
and starting with a black victory
against magnus carlsen what a way to do
it yeah or as i said to me prior to
entering these tournaments who cares if
i get invited to play olympics or
anything else next year my rating is
going to be so high that they have no
way to exclude me
the comments just keep on coming and
that looked amazing where's the palm
trees in the background and the atlantic
ocean in the background in miami the
action is going on inside the eden rock
hotel on miami beach magnus carlson is
fighting for a comeback he lost game one
two the american hans niemann playing in
his home country but now the bar is over
two magnus crawls on the side but he
spent almost three minutes now on this
move what is he thinking about i think
it's just the fact that he has too many
tempting options here
this is the type of position i would
probably spend 10 minutes just because
it's so hard to pick between
three tempting continuations and three
very promising content uh continuations
i should add
so what would you guys do here maybe if
we pull the board up we can try and get
inside magnus's mind
what is the world champion thinking is
he gonna i mean the first move you
calculate i guess is taking this pawn or
this pawn um because in chess we always
look for the most forcing most ambitious
moves first
yeah i was drawn to capturing the pawn
closest to the king you know take that
pawn weaken the king and then once the
king runs then i guess
yeah oh yeah this would be a check and
this would be very good for black but
the king most likely just steps to the
side yeah okay he didn't go for this i
guess the problem here for magnus is
there is a pin on this uh on this
diagonal the black bishop is uh slightly
vulnerable instead magnus went for maybe
the safe approach uh not the most
ambitious he moved his queen to this
square so same idea just different order
um so attacking this pawn and attacking
the white bishops and uh hans therefore
needs to trade off as many pieces as
possible so we arrive in this position
level pawns level pieces but uh black's
bishop is the dominant of the two and uh
now attack on this form yeah you attack
on the spawn as well definitely i
thought uh hans move was quite good
actually because it was more or less
forced and kind of controls every single
pawn but magnus
he uh captures the pawn anyway yup he
has spotted that the white queen is
actually overworked um she has two jobs
to do here she wants to defend this
square but she also has to defend her
bishop so now if the black bishop is
indeed captured then magnus will go a
pawn up whether this is enough to win
it's unclear because we might well reach
a rook in game eventually and uh black
is yet to create a passport but
this is a risk-free advantage for magnus
the question is here if you were hands
would you capture this bishop would you
trade off as many pieces as possible or
would you maybe just move the rook and
say okay opposite color bishops
long term that gives drawing chances as
well it's definitely white playing for
the draw now yeah i would keep the
bishops on the board and hans says yes
he would too it's interesting because i
would uh i think i wouldn't hesitate
here i would take the bishops off as
long as the queens are on the board i
would be terrified
of allowing the bishops to stay because
with opposite colour bishops it's easier
to attack the enemy king white's king
here has only three pawns shelter
black's king has four pawns
um also i'm looking at this bishop it's
not in a great diagonal anymore uh
diagonal is just staring at a kind of a
rock
a concrete uh foothold here for black
i think it'd be more impressive if hans
draws this game than actually winning
the last one yeah um against magnus
because he's a safe pawn down um at this
kind of position that magnus thrives in
um you know just nurturing that small
advantage uh you've got to defend not
nice defending
uh and as you say the opposite kind of
bishops are not really a problem here
there's too many pieces on the board so
this is uh this is going to be very very
tough for for hands to
to save i think i mean just chances of
course but he needs to swap off all the
rooks really uh in order to save this
game
or the queens as well um okay magnus
interesting move i was just thinking
okay move the queen out the way not to
that square sorry uh to this one just
get the queen out of uh any threat from
the white rooks but instead magnus tries
to create a pin
along this line
oh yes still i mean
it's gonna be so hard for hans to even
survive the next few moves and uh kind
of without going too passive
i'm scared for the american now yeah
yeah i mean it's definitely
an interesting position because of that
imbalance with the opposite color
bishops you know and magnus playing very
accurately
but somehow i feel that
hans maybe could do something and he
steps his queen up and attacks the
bishop perhaps uh thinking at
the right time maybe stepping up his
king and maybe lining up the bishop and
queen along the same diagonal uh i think
there's still a lot of play left in the
position and i have to say it's terrible
weather here i think it is awful yeah i
mean thunderstorms
lightning okay queen fans the bishop and
uh it's but it seems like the rest of
the world is having
great i mean we saw it was fantastic in
miami sirenplovgot says he sends us
greetings from orson's and denmark and
nice sunny weather that's so close to
here how how is the sun shining in
denmark
i prefer the rain
it's been it's been so sunny in england
we've had like four or five weeks of a
heat wave i would just love to stand in
the rain now literally i just like you
know just get the water from my face but
you know the rain is nice you know the
rain's nice as well so
how has that heat wave been and
is it over now
uh i think it's still going on but it's
supposed to rain soon so it's uh it's
been pretty horrendous in england yeah
just
relentless sun
and which might sound lovely but you
know england's not really prepared for
that and neither are gingers either
yeah not not not good for me yeah
yeah and i heard the situation and we
have some moves on the board obviously
just to interrupt us david but it was
extremely hot in chennai as well correct
yeah most days were over 30 degrees it
was very humid as well
but indoors was air-conditioned and i
think the biggest problem for the
players is that um
indoors was nice and cool but as soon as
you step out you're sweating immediately
and then the playing hall was very cold
i heard a lot of complaints about that
yeah actually it was very interesting um
i mean i found the better women
complained than the men loved it
that was then it was very cold because
we were freezing we were sat there in
jackets and everything and you could see
every woman was like this
and uh
yeah it was the first tournament in
years that i've worn a jacket at the
board normally i take the jacket off
it's just a shirt uh during a game but i
had to put the jacket on uh it was just
especially when players would leave the
hall because then there were fewer
bodies less warmth oh yeah the longer
the games go on the colder you feel and
yeah i did hear of a lot of players
falling ill some of the top players they
didn't play as many games for their
countries they wanted to just because
they were struggling with the climate
it's got toughen up wimps
[Laughter]
women needs to start controlling the
temperature in chess tournament
arenas maybe
yeah definitely kaya
okay and meanwhile there's been a set of
trades actually a pair of rooks have
left the board and uh oh i think this
increases the chances for hans to secure
that very important draw but on the
other hand you know when i do compare
the bishops i mean why is bishop not
great
just uh biting on a brick wall you know
black's bishop is just awesome
yeah and uh you guys know i did release
this chess ball course with magnusson
grinding um kind of out these small
advantages and this is the perfect
scenario to grind as black for zero risk
you're a pawn up worse comes the worst
you trade off the queens and rooks and
it's just a draw with opposite colour
bishops but you can just kind of tease
your opponent for the next 50 moves you
just slowly kind of step forward the
black kings maybe push a pawn here or
there just try to occupy some open files
with your pieces and white can't really
force all the exchanges david anytime
soon so this is like uh yeah it's a
dream scenario to kind of press with no
risk if i had white against you here i'd
just resign
i
i could not give you the satisfaction of
just
just slowly killing me here you know i'd
be like yeah cheers
i don't accept your resignation
there used to be a rule where you can
refuse resignation oh it used to be that
i think that was some weird rule i don't
know but yeah anyway i mean the queens
are off but yeah
it's still
maybe just still seems very good for
black but if the rooks come off though
it will be a draw so that's definitely
but take a look at magnus's last move
you know he just pushed pawn forward you
know and uh i suspect that he might be
you know what keith said about this
movie for grand master keith arcol he
did this course for us and for chesapore
he's done an end game course and
very he's got some very interesting
little terminologies and he said as
black if you can ever play the move g5
this last move which is his favorite
move you're always doing well
because if you're playing it in the
opening it's a sign that you're
attacking your position is good in the
middle game you're gaining space and the
ending is a good move so and that's
actually quite interesting actually if
you're ever able to play g5 you're doing
well as black which i thought was just
weird but good move though i think yeah
definitely i was impressed uh
david yeah i loved it uh from the black
side and meanwhile white's moved just
shuffling his rook across that did evoke
a kind of frown from magnus
uh magnus slightly surprised by that one
also i'm looking at black's clock time
magnus is really going to enjoy uh
trying to grind out this advantage and i
mean black's plans here we should maybe
talk about why this is such a good move
in the end game but black's plans are
relatively simple uh in this position
here white kind of wants to push this
pawn forward when you have a four versus
three um disadvantage here uh four black
has the four white has the three you
always want to step your pawn forward
for example to this square because here
your pawns connect together you only
ever have to worry about the base of the
pawn chain this is the only weakness
that black can ever attack
yes black has great winning chances but
um at least it's less to worry about for
white but the fact that black was able
to achieve this move means that long
term this pawn is also a weakness it can
never find a safe square where it's
protected by another white pawn and for
example if it ever steps up uh in this
scenario it will just become isolated
these are two weaknesses now so black
has two weaknesses to target this is why
this pawn push is such an important one
and uh if you compare that to white uh
here what can white target there's
nothing white can ever
go for and i'm slightly surprised magnus
is pushing forward so quickly but he has
clamped down so these two pawns are now
fixed
and they won't be able to move for at
least a while i guess there are also
ideas of swinging the rook across going
for this pawn which sits on a dark
square all of these white pawns actually
sit on dart square so they are all
targets
whereas the black pawns that sit on
light squares they are hard to attack
this white bishop still it's on a safe
square but it's just staring at a
granite statue it's just
not ever really going to create any
threats on its own
it's just one way traffic black is going
to start advancing the king start
advancing the pawn
the rule i learned is that if you're
trying to win opposite kind of bishop
ending we see some exchanges here
probably is that you uh want to put your
pawn pawns on the same kind of square as
your opponent's bishop
and if you're trying to draw the
position you want to put your pawns on
the opposite color square to your
opponent's bishop um i you know i don't
know how true that is but that that's
certainly what's happening here you're
trying to keep white's pawns on dark
squares where you can attack them with
your
bishop um and
well
okay sorry you carry on simon no yeah i
mean some porn exchanges here but this
this looks like white's totally tied
down right here
and now you can see magnus is really
massaging his advantage through you know
he's pushed forward with more pawns
the black king is going to step forward
and there's just no move
that our hands can do apart from just
wait with the bishop
unpleasant stuff here very very
unpleasant i think this is already a
winning advantage for black um the thing
is you can't kind of use your bishop to
destabilize this black rook it's just
fixed on this square if you ever try to
kind of step back
to go for this rook then firstly black
can ignore this because at the very
least black's root can swing across and
target another weakness
but if you want to be really kind of
if you really want to cut across your
opponent's plans then you can just step
this pawn forward and it's it's exactly
what simon said actually here um the
pawns control the light squares the
bishop controls the dark squares and
that's why it's such a good strategy
instead white's king took a step back uh
if we retreat back to this position and
magnus we know that he loves to push his
rooks pawns forward the anh pawns he's
getting ready to kind of push this one
down ready for a race upon race later
and
hans is just completely stuck if the
bishop now retreats to kick away this
black rook uh magnus his idea i guess is
to swing it across attack this pawn and
if the bishop comes back now we see the
idea behind this pawn push he would kick
away this bishop and sooner or later
something is going to drop
black has ideas now of some uh checks
yeah this bishop no longer has a safe
square it's just all falling apart for
hands yeah definitely i mean just seeing
that
white's bishop and white's work are
pretty useless i mean is now the time to
perhaps just kind of
get active with the with the rook and
i'm just thinking you know maybe grab
the g4 pawn but okay he instead he goes
for the wait and see approach it's very
difficult to do that just to sit there
and wait for the axe to fall yeah i mean
if white is just resigned to putting
this king back and forth back and forth
then white uh then black will slowly but
surely start pushing forward okay he is
going for the strategy maybe even black
can start going um towards this uh side
of the board with his king
okay he is on this journey
might as well just resign if you're
doing this yeah
you like to resign at least i'm in it
doesn't seem that way it
it really does yeah what's the point of
suffering in a hopeless situation yeah i
mean against magnets i'd resign anyway i
think here against david i resigned
against most players i'd resign actually
all right yeah
we've got to stop this
what's happening nobody ever won a game
by resigning silence yeah i know well
apparently that's not true
oh really yeah apparently there's a
in the folklore there's a story that
someone someone resigned
and then the other person felt so guilty
that the the person resigned that they
said no we don't i don't accept the
resignation i'm going to resign because
what had transpired was that earlier on
the guy had cheated
and played something illegal and then he
got such a
struck by some
ha
worst cheat ever yeah yeah yeah you got
away with it
that's right and you lost anyway
well it seems to be all about the black
pieces
here today so far in the first round two
games ended up with winners and they
both had the black pieces in game twos
here going on right now well the bar
seems to be all the way over to the
black player's side young christoph duda
looking good for him against lavon
aronian and ali reza ferrugia the bar
all the way over to his side in game two
against liam leah the first game between
those two was a draw and of course this
one magnus carlsen is he making a
comeback against hans niem on the bar
keeps
going up for the world champion and it's
that type of advantage that will keep
growing um it's just inevitable i mean
what what i found very i
like trying to break these games down
to learn something and um i think what i
found quite incredible about this was
how quickly
magnus went for this particular ending
so he quickly swapped off one rook
quickly swapped off one queen and it's
like we weren't sure i mean especially
in event you know we were like should he
be swapping the queen off i'm like okay
i'm not sure but he did it immediately
knowing exactly what he was aiming for
and that's the kind of thing that you
know the the level and the intuition
that magnus has and other top ground
masters they show that we can learn from
you know he's going for a particular set
up this particular kind of ending
and he knew exactly what he wanted when
he went for that exchange i just find
that really
you know good to learn from basically
those kind of ideas um for future yeah
he actually talked about basically the
pawn structure that we had on the king
side a bit earlier when the queen's came
off he talked about that exact pawn
structure in our chest of course and he
talked about which minor pieces you want
from the attacking side uh and which
pieces kind of which assortment of
pieces you want on the defensive side
and he was saying okay opposite color
bishops here as long as there are rooks
on the board very good winning chances
um same thing of course david it sounds
fast
it has some little nuggets actually i
learned a lot from listening to magnus
but same color bishops even if there are
rooks on the board easy draw and he was
showing kind of setups um that kind of
fixed the draw there and you're right
simon that's kind of that kind of
knowledge and that experience from
grinding out these end games from
playing them non-stop for i mean magnus
has been playing these end games for 20
plus years but that's how he kind of
his uh judgment is so uh so kind of in
tune with the position because he knows
exactly what he wants in the end game
and uh that affects his
traditions in the opening and middle
game he's enjoying this and you can buy
this course we should say so it is on
chesapore right david
and it's on sale as well
yeah right now you can save i think
actually 60 dollars right now on this
amazing course with the world champion
and the olympic gold medalist
i kind of wish uh we hadn't released it
yet and we added this game from uh yeah
this is a perfect example of how to just
kind of obtain an advantage early in the
game here it was a porn advantage but
then kind of
accumulate those small edges and
transform them into what is likely now
to be a victory
for carlson and he's barely spent any
time on the clock this game has been
pure instinct from the world champion
it's just decision making it's not
calculation at all it's just uh okay
i've won a pawn now i want the queen's
off i want the rooks off i want to push
my pawn to this square fix your
opponent's pawns i want to paralyze the
opponent's pieces it's just general
rules rather than specific moves
and yeah hands reduce to waiting still
the hammer will fall eventually at some
point either black's king will go over
towards that lonely white a pawn or okay
he's going to get ready to push one of
the pawns in the center of the board
yeah i mean is is black even threatening
to push his e pawn one square forward
and then
try to kind of do a golden run
and uh win two pawns at once
that looks like uh it would be very very
strong magnus he won't want to take any
risk though
i was gonna say he will pause and
calculate a little bit but uh no he just
goes for this immediately
and how is white gonna save that g-pawn
now
can the white king step to the right he
has to otherwise he would have gone two
pawns down but now there's going to be a
discovered check yeah and the king is
steps back and suddenly that bishop
doesn't have a safe place to go
has to go on the edge of the board he's
not going to find cindy's solace there
the king can attack it again yeah yeah
that's right
really nice way to finish right yeah
exactly wherever the bishop goes the
black rook will move it's a discover
check and the bishop falls maybe you
just have to use the white rook to
defend it now and
cross your fingers but
like that one i think is losing either
way
this one
unfortunately chess speaks for itself
and um
you got it in there so yeah
but i mean it's setting up a really
exciting
uh next two games between these two yeah
yeah very interesting they will be tied
after two games and remember the formats
and the major they play four rapid games
to decide each match best out of four
rapid games and the winner takes three
points the loser is zero points but if
they are tied
then we will head straight to blitz tie
breaks and the winner in thai race gets
two points the loser one point and we
didn't see any tie breaks yesterday
we have to see some today that would be
very strange
yeah
we've seen surprisingly few this season
i know we keep expecting them
the players they're so aggressive so
direct magnus has won a second pawn and
there we go hans resigns
oh
what a comeback it was by hans niemann
in the first game but world champion
magnus carlson he makes a comeback of
himself